we begin tonight with a Fox News Alert
the witch-hunt is officially over the
Muller report is out and the President
of the United States has been totally
and completely vindicated
watch this I'm having a good day - who's
called no collusion no obstructions
there never was by the way and there
never will be and we do have to get to
the bottom of these things I will say
and this should never happened this
should never happen to another president
again this hoax should never happen to
another president again and we're gonna
do our part to make sure it doesn't
happen again we're holding those people
accountable we have a lot to get to
tonight but for the past two and a half
years the leader of the free world was
forced to dedicate so much precious time
energy resources to an unjust
investigation surrounding what is a hoax
here's the bottom line directly from the
Muller report quote the investigation
did not establish that members of the
Trump campaign conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government in its
election interference activities the
president's team of lawyers are
rightfully triumphant writing quote the
results of the investigation are a total
victory for the president the report
underscores what we have argued from the
very beginning there was no collusion
there was no obstruction it is clear
there was no criminal wrongdoing nothing
withheld nothing concealed
oh nothing deleted nothing destroyed and
nothing bleached that's right no bleach
pit
unlike Hillary Clinton the president
didn't destroy subpoenaed emails or any
other evidence in this case he did not
invoke executive privilege instead
according to former independent counsel
Ken Starr the president's cooperation in
this case was unprecedented and that's
because President Trump had nothing to
hide
thousands and thousands of documents
were turned over almost 1.4 million
unfettered access given to trump
campaign officials administration
employees Muller's team completed 30
hours of interviews with the White House
Counsel how does that ever happen no
executive privilege was used to hide
anything in Muller's report by contrast
the Obama administration oh they used
executive privilege to withhold 20
emails from then Attorney General Eric
Holder surrounding his involvement in
the fast and furious gun-running scandal
well that was a real scandal whereas
Trump
rusha collusion was a farce tonight
thankfully for the sake of this country
truth has prevailed as the president's
attorneys put a quote this vindication
of the president is an important step
forward for the country and a strong
reminder that this type of abuse must
never be permitted to occur again now
coming up in the monologue we're gonna
take you through the real crimes that
will be exposed we're going to call out
all of the Democrats the media mob who
have spent 2.5 years lying defrauding
the American people and mark my words an
avalanche of truth and justice is about
to bury all of those who abuse their
power two and a half years never ending
non-stop tinfoil conspiracy theorists
and the media mob obsessed on a level of
psychosis we've never seen every day
Russia Russia Russia collusion collusion
collusion after four separate
investigations including a nine month
FBI investigation a house Intel
investigation the bipartisan
investigation in the Senate and now the
all-powerful Muller probe we know zero
Trump Russia collusion Glenn Greenwald
put it very well
Robert Muller did not merely reject the
Trump Russia conspiracy theories he
obliterated them this today mark this
day is the biggest beat-down the media
mob has ever experienced in history
because every time they mentioned Russia
Russia Russia every time they said
collusion collusion collusion we now
know it was a lie two and a half years
of lie after lie after lie
conspiracy theories posing as news
programs by the way how stupid what must
Rachel Maddow and her bland band a
blithering conspiracy theorist filled
today in a moment we are going to show
you these lies that they are peddled
part of it may make you laugh part of it
will make you sad for two and a half
years you we the American people you
have been the victims of the biggest con
job in American history every second
every hour
every day the Democrats the hate Trump
medium mob all others perpetrating a lie
every time they said Russia Russia
Russia collusion collusion
they were smearing besmirching
slandering trying to undo an election a
duly elected president of the United
States all day every day Russia Russia
collusion collusion just to take you
down memory lane and remind you of these
lies
non-stop conspiracy theories and lies
we're about to find out if the new
president of our country is going to do
what Russia wants as if there are no
shoes on the Trump Human Centipede that
are not about Russia Russia Russia
Russia this cloud about collusion with
Russia will hang over him no matter
where he stands he may be the first
president in quite some time to face the
real prospect of jail time I think
they're shocked that the noose is
tightening it's clear that mother is now
connecting the dots between a massive
obstruction intended to hide the truth
this president needs to be impeached I
believe that I believe there was
collusion Donald Trump's done he's done
there's no question about he's got to
know his future looks like it's behind
bars we have a treasonous president he
feels the world is closing in on him the
president's done everything he can in
trashing the special counsel mr. Trump
is seeing more and more of the walls
closing in on him which is why he is
becoming increasingly desperate what if
he refuses to open the White House door
what if the secret you know will the Kin
what if he fires any Secret Service
agent who would allow the federal
marshals in what if Donald Trump simply
decides I don't have to follow the law I
refuse to be held under the law no
marshal can get into this White House
unbelievable conspiracy theories lies
they betrayed their audience they don't
care at all about the truth just look at
what they did look at what they did to a
16 year old Nicholas Sandman tried to
destroy a 16 year old kid with nothing
but baseless like they didn't even make
one phone call to try and confirm the
story they just make it up and they
bludgeoned a sixteen-year-old kid just
for wearing a maggot
that's how much these people in the
media in the Democratic Party hate Trump
now there was no basic research in the
case of Jesse mullet the narrative works
to bash Trump use it let's not forget
the I believers when it came to justice
Cavanaugh or when they set out to
destroy go back to Richard Jewell the
Duke Lacrosse kids the students at the
Center for the fake UVA rape case the
Cambridge Police smear the Ferguson
police officer Darren Wilson guilt by
the media accusation or the Baltimore
Police guilt by accusation by the way on
every one of those cases we were right
they were wrong we saw it over and over
again on Trump Russia collusion
collusion false reports that Don jr.
would be found guilty of crimes Jared
Kushner guilty Melania Ivanka other
family members smeared slandered
besmirched around every turn by
sanctimonious self-righteous frankly
overpaid lazy agenda-driven liars in the
news media conspiracy theorists no shame
whatsoever and today where are the
apologies
where are the retractions where are the
corrections nowhere to be found just the
opposite it now double down on hysteria
breathless reckless reporting and now
it's obstruction obstruction obstruction
if Muller could he and his partisan team
of democratic donors and Hillary lovers
they would have found crimes but now
with zero introspection no self
reflective reflection no apology it's
just on like it never happened let's go
to the next pack of lies the next round
of breathless reporting the next
manufactured scandal to destroy Trump a
psychotic rage in every so-called
newsroom in America all while ignoring
simultaneously what is the biggest story
in their careers and lifetime because of
their blind adherence to rigid left-wing
loving Hillary ideology so it's no shock
that just as we predicted yesterday the
media mob and their echo chamber they've
back in action with one last full-on
hysterical freak out over the Muller
investigation this is a sad disturbing
grand finale
for what has now been over two years of
this this lying campaign to destroy a
president and of course we the people
you know the smelly Walmart voters that
cling to our God gun Bibles and religion
the irredeemable deplorable
oh don't think they like us any better
take a look this was an investigation at
its core about Donald Trump's daily
sometimes hourly assault on the rule of
law in this country as the country's
chief executive he sat in his pajamas
watching Fox and Friends maligning the
FBI the you know built our didn't walk
into that room with the scale at zero
rule of law had a deficit because Donald
Trump have been kicking it in the teeth
can I just talk about this issue of the
president's concerns about leagues you
know who else was concerned about leaks
Richard Nixon this report is a gift to
the government of Russia
this is a very proud moment for Vladimir
Putin the amount of information that
relates to collusion and obstruction
activity is really quite extensive in
this report they're significant there's
a sink their significant material in
here that we did not know on the
question of collusions it's here in
substance in nuance in context and it's
there for all people of goodwill in this
country if they're not so dug in
politically or ideologically to process
the information and make some
sophisticated judgments and the other
thing in this report date is that it
really corroborated a lot of the good
journalism that was done Muller a highly
respected investigator in law
enforcement official he could not find
sufficient evidence that there was
conspiracy by any American knowingly or
by any member of the Trump tank team
that's great news but Barr repeating it
over and over and over again six or
seven times I mean that's that's a
little excessive as you can see just
more and more fake news and even some
collusion truthers desperately clinging
on to a totally fake claim others now
they're shifting the narrative to
obstruction of justice on the
president's taxes the president was not
charged he was cleared
obstruction not by Muller not by the
Attorney General of the United States
who emphasized today that obstruction
just did not occur
it did not sorry the report recounts 10
episodes involving the President and
discusses potential legal theories for
connecting those activities to the
elements of an obstruction offense after
carefully reviewing the facts and legal
theories outlined in the report and in
consultation with the Office of Legal
Counsel and other department lawyers the
Deputy Attorney General and I concluded
that the evidence developed by the
special counsel is not sufficient to
establish that the president committed
an obstruction of justice offense top
law enforcement official in the US the
Attorney General is Deputy Attorney
General the office of legal counsel all
agree no obstruction no collusion yes
the president talked about the ways to
curtail the Special Counsel
investigation yeah I'm sure it was
frustrating yeah he discussed firing
Muller the president openly hoping that
an American war hero of 33 years
including combat experienced Lieutenant
General Flynn wouldn't face charges yes
the president expressed frustration and
anger that his presidency was being
burdened with an investigation that
which is a hoax you know talking
thinking tweeting they are not crimes if
the president wanted to sink the Special
Counsel investigation
he had Article two authority under the
Constitution he could have personally
fired Robert Muller or anyone else for
that matter the president did not fire
Muller or Rosen Stein or Weissman or JD
ray or any of the other Clinton donors
and allies investigating this this
shamness campaign the president took no
action to impede the prosecution of
Lieutenant General Flynn or Paul
Manafort or George papadopolis or anyone
else and as we stated earlier the
president engaged in an unprecedented
level of cooperation with the Special
Counsel and above all else
there was no underlying crime none two
and a half years Russia Russia collusion
collusion now
all lies it's
take this country's collective breath
away and according to Moses report in
2017 the president reacted to the
appointment of the special counsel quote
oh my god this is terrible this is the
end of my presidency I'm bleeped but the
president trumpeted Trump didn't say
that because he was guilty of a crime
but read a little further it was about
concerns about how will impact and
effect his presidency and the country
quote everyone tells me if you get one
of these independent councils it ruins
your presidency it takes years and years
and I won't be able to do anything
that's where his thought process was and
actually context matters doesn't it the
president is not being charged with
obstruction because obstruction didn't
exist now the media mob lashing out one
last time and at the new attorney
general Bob William bar because he won't
do their bidding more psychotic rage
from your friends in the fake news
industry they can't help themselves it
is a mass psychosis at this point at the
age of 68 bill Barr has decided his
legacy he is fine with his legacy being
the AG who took one for the team we
would not be surprised if some headline
writer somewhere came up with Baghdad
bill bar for what we saw today it was
excessive and suspicious mr. Barr today
violated all the norms that had been
established post Watergate and took us
back right into Nick Sounion type
operations as I wrote notes made notes
of what Barr was saying I reached a
point where I just wrote down Barr
continues to shill for the president
sometimes you can have an attorney
general who's just compromised for one
reason or another really Brian Williams
you're the same guy that saw dead bodies
at Katrina in areas where there's no
water you're gonna lecture anybody come
up with a few names for you any of these
people were actually concerned with
obstruction okay why did they ignore the
biggest slam dunk case of obstruction in
modern history look at your screen as we
told you last night
Hillary Clinton
she did commit an underlying crime a
clear violation of the Espionage Act we
know for a fact it's incontrovertible
she stored classified top-secret
information
marked as such on an unsecured server
she deleted then 33,000 subpoenaed
emails she asked it washed her hard
drives with bleach pit she removed the
SIM card had AIDS destroy her devices
blackberrys iphones with a hammer oh so
she had intent crucial to the crime that
was committed and the intent was to
destroy the evidence
but now equal justice is coming pay
close attention because what we're about
to play out here in front of America in
the coming days weeks and months is
everything we've been telling you the
Clinton email investigation is now being
probed by Senator Lindsey Graham because
the fix was in that investigation were
was rigged criminal referrals from the
deep state operatives that tried to help
elect Hillary Clinton giving her a pass
on a crime she committed yeah they're
gonna have criminal referrals from Devon
Nunez we're also going to get the
horowitz FISA investigation imagine that
the bulk of that information and the
FISA application was Hillary Clinton's
bought and paid for
Russian dossier the Ober investigation
is also going on about leaking now the
president last time we interviewed him
right here on this program the FBI's
302s conversations Christopher Steele
Bruce or etc they will be coming out yes
the FISA applications against Carter
page the bulk of information Hillary's
bought and paid for Russian lies they're
all coming out the gang of eight
information FBI admitting wrongdoing in
some of that I'm told and for all you
Democrats you claim to love transparency
well buckle up you're about to get what
you've been wishing for and it won't
paint a pretty pretty picture in any way
of your friends in the deep State and
we're talking about you Loretta Lynch
clearly you interfered in the Clinton
email investigation we now know that
investigation was completely rigged to
save Hillary from being indicted you
know the matter not the investigation
and we're not just talking about the
secret meeting on the tarmac with
clinton days before the decision or the
time you instructed call me to call it a
matter not an investigation look at
these newly released transcript
closed-door testimony even struck and
page they're admitting the DOJ
controlled all of this rigging the
Clinton probe from the beginning they
knew the fix was in so what did Loretta
Lynch know when did she know it where's
her emails where's her text messages
what about national security director
Susan Rice why did unmasking request in
an election year 2016 increase almost
three hundred and fifty percent under
her watch what did Rice know when did
she know it why would the UN Ambassador
Samantha Power's request Oh a hundred of
maskings and then say oh I didn't really
request that she didn't and who did then
we go to our good friend the man who
stands above it all James Comey why did
he sign off on that first FISA warrant
in October of 2016 to spy on the Trump
campaign associate Carter page using
Hillary's bought and paid for phony
Russian dossiers the bulk of evidence
that means that he's signing off that
it's true and accurate to the best of
his knowledge we now know it was never
verified and we also know it's
unverifiable because Christopher Steele
he doesn't even stand by his own dossier
remember he told the Trump Donald Trump
old president-elect at the time when he
went to Trump Tower that the contents of
the dossier was salacious and unverified
yet three months before he went before a
FISA judge and said the dossier was true
incorrect three months earlier so the
question for Jim Comey tonight is did
you lie in October 2016 or January of
2017 and by the way why did Sally Yates
and dated bhante and rod Rosen Stein who
signed off on the last FISA warrant why
did they sign off on something that's
unverifiable by the way we can't forget
about John Brennan James clapper were
they trafficking the dirty dossier
throughout the federal government by the
way who leaked it to izikoff david korn
the washington post did they leak it to
impact the election with Russian lies to
bludgeon the president-elect who told
Harry Reid and let's not forget struck
in pay
and Andrew McCabe and the partisan Trump
aiding high-ranking FBI officials who
rigged that whole investigation into
Clinton because she was the favorite
candidate that should win a hundred
million a zero and the people that were
voting for Trump like me and you we were
just smelly
Walmart shoppers so many questions will
be answered now that we know there were
spies inside the Trump campaign here's
another question
was there any outsourcing of
intelligence gathering in other words
were there any efforts by high-ranking
members of our Intel community to bypass
American laws and maybe use our British
Australian Italian spy friends to
surveil the Trump campaign and by the
way who got to Stefan Halper who asked
him would to covertly meet with
Papadopoulos and Carter Paige and Sam
Clovis and by the way who recruited him
from our federal government because
clearly it happened and if any of this
started before July 31st the alleged
beginning of the FBI's collusion
investigation we need to know when it
started and finally we need to know this
big question what did he know what did
President Obama know and when did he
know it all of this happened under his
watch here's what's coming here's what I
heard it is coming in the days weeks and
months ahead we will get answers to all
these pressing questions the hate Trump
media mob Democrats deep state they will
get burned with a barrage an avalanche
of truth and evidence the likes of which
they have no idea is coming oh they
don't want to know